[MUSIC]
Thank you very much for joining us today.
We couldn't imagine a better speaker for
this memorial lecture.
We have all sorts of topics to
discuss from your investing career,
to your work on the environment,
to your recent political activism.
Before we get there, I wanted to start
with your time as a GSB student.
Back when you were in these seats,
metaphorically speaking,
did you ever imagine you would be on this
stage as a view from the top speaker?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I can't say I was thinking this far
forward, and I can't say
I really understood the significance when
I was going to Stanford Business School,
to Stanford Business School,
in terms of leadership in our society.
So, I think I have a different perspective
of the importance of this institution now.
And obviously, I'm a lot older and
have [INAUDIBLE]
and wouldn't have time for anything.
>> Fair enough.
I mean, we're all facing the same
types of constraints here.
Another question for you, what was your
most influential class at the GSB?
>> So, I think I'd chase two classes,
I'll equivocate.
One was touchy feely.
I don't know,
do they still do interpersonal dynamics?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes.
>> So, I love touchy feely,
because it was a chance to see how
people interact in a much more
honest way than when people
are normally very controlled.
And also, when I went home for Christmas
break, and my father looked at me and
goes, is this a class, seriously?
So I love that too, just annoying him.
But I also took a course here in
International Economics that was,
I thought absolutely brilliant
in terms about thinking about
basically competitive
advantage on a national level.
And thinking about what makes societies
work, what makes societies productive,
why do some societies
move forward really well?
And what are the reasons that other
societies have continuing problems?
And I thought that was something that
I never looked at so systematically.
It was really a brilliant course.
>> Speaking of making societies
productive, let's now turn to
your early days as an investor.
You were a rising star at Goldman
when Wall Street was booming, and
in less than a year,
you had moved to San Francisco to start-up
a small merger arbitrage hedge fund.
What gave you the confidence
to make this sudden change?
>> So let's be clear,
when I moved back out here from Goldman,
first of all,
my wife wanted to live west
of the Mississippi, period.
So, I knew that Goldman Sachs
was in New York,
and therefore,
I was going to have to leave.
It's also true that I got in a gigantic
fight with a guy I was working for,
and therefore, I felt like, under no
circumstances do I want to continue to
go to work and see that guy every morning.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which was not a great career move.
But also,
I felt like one of the things I love about
investing is you can measure the results.
And I felt like, if I do a bad job at
Goldman Sachs, they're going to fire me.
If I do a bad job on my own,
I'm also going to get fired.
But if I do a good job on my own,
I'd have much more upside
then I do at Goldman Sachs.
And so, I didn't think I was taking more
risk because I felt like, either way,
if you don't do a good job in life,
it doesn't work out.
So, I was more than willing to
bet on myself in the sense that
if you're taking that risk anyway, why
not at least give yourself the up side?
>> And have the opportunity to go surfing
on weekends is helpful.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We did want to live west of
the Mississippi.
>> [LAUGH] You then went
from $10 million in seed capital,
to managing about $20 billion by the time
you stepped down from Fairlawn in 2012.
What challenges did you face as the fund
scaled, particularly those related to
leadership?
>> First of all,
one of the things that we tried
to do was to grow gradually.
Because I felt if you went from
$10 million to $20 million,
that wasn't a step function,
so that you could
change your team slowly enough, so
that you continue to do the job.
If you went from $10
million to $300 million,
you're in a completely different business,
and you're taking a gigantic risk,
with whether you have the capability
to actually perform that function.
So, we really grew very consistently,
but we never grew geometrically.
I will say this, when I think back
to what we were doing at Farallon,
and when I'm mad at myself, I think
that there's a rule in organizations
that up to 125 people, you don't
have to be that formally organized.
And I remember being here in the HP wave,
management by walking around.
That's what I really like to do,
was just talk to everybody, and try and
stay up to date, and
hear what the problems were.
And we had a very open office
physically so that there were no walls.
There were no offices, so that there
was a lot of internal communication,
whether people wanted it or not.
I think above 125 people,
you start to really need rules, and
you really need hierarchy, and you
really need a way of organizing people.
And we did do that.
But if there's one thing that I would
fault myself for, and I do get mad about
it is, I think at some point,
we had a very, very flat organization.
And I really did feel like we made
decisions listening to everybody
very clearly, and we didn't really
have a hierarchical decision making.
And if I were doing it again, I would be a
little more insistent that the people who
proved themselves, into which I would
throw my name, should get a little more
decision making than some of the people
who thought they knew a heck of a lot and
then would be like, my gosh,
I had no idea that would happen.
Usually I'm like, well,
that's what I was talking to you about for
the last six months.
And so, I, there is, when I think back
to growth as you get more larger,
you actually have to
able to have some system,
where the senior people really do have
to listen, have to take into account.
But ultimately, they're supposed to be
in the position that they're going to
get hung if it doesn't turn
out to be a good decision,
so the younger people
should defer to them,
until they can get in that position.
>> As you were growing consistently, one
thing that was also growing was Fairlawn's
investments in the coal industry.
Fairlawn became one of the major
players in sustaining and
growing the coal industry in Australia,
Indonesia, and China.
Knowing what you know now, in a different
time, would you have made those
investments again?
>> No.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Look, I would say, somewhere around
ten years ago,
basically I was sitting here
thinking about what was going to
turn out to be a huge problem.
And I started to really focus on climate,
and
then I started to look at all
our investments differently.
And so, it really was a situation
where I felt like up till then,
we invested in every single industry
including fossil fuels, which were
probably less than proportionate to what
they are in the whole worldwide economy,
or the American economy, but
definitely significant investments.
And starting about ten years ago,
I realized,
wow, this is just going
to be a gigantic problem.
And I've gotta not only stop doing this,
but I've gotta get out of this,
which I did do, and have done.
But I feel like, do I wish that I'd
come to that conclusion 10 years or 20?
Of course I do.
Do I wish I were taller and
playing center in the NBA, yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I wish I were smarter and
had figured it out sooner.
But I think that we're really coming from
as a society is exactly the same place,
which is this.
Our society was based
around fossil fuel energy.
That's just the truth.
We all drive cars, we've all grown up
in a society where electricity was
largely based on fossil fuels.
It's not a question of that.
The question is what are we
going to do about it, and
how fast can we move away from it, and
how fast do we have to move away from it?
So of course I wish that when my good
friend Dan Lashof was writing his PhD
thesis on climate change in 1989,
that I was like Dan's absolutely right.
We should be really careful about this.
But it took me longer than,
obviously, the sooner the better,
but I feel like ten years ago,
I came to that conclusion.
And I decided this is really important,
that this is a thing that
will be critical for
our society and critical for
everyone on this planet, so therefore,
we can't equivocate about it,
wish I'd been smarter.
>> Could we drill down on that
moment a little?
Because I think there's a very deep
amount of thought that you put into this
particular issue, and yet, there's so
many issues out there in the world.
And you've spoken about many,
you've spoken about inequality, and
you've spoken about tobacco, and
the harms that it poses to society.
You've gone through many different topics.
How is it that climate resonated so
deeply?
And specifically,
what you saw at that time ten years ago?
>> Well,
let me give you my thinking then,
which is this.
I mean, I know the GSPS has a ton
of foreign born students, but
as an American,
I felt like our system basically works.
And the way it basically works
is we're rude, we're vulgar,
we're loud, we disagree with each other.
But if everybody's trying to solve
the problem, regardless of where they're
coming from, we compromise,
we solve the problem, we move on.
And everyone else is thinking
they're very rude and loud,
which is true, but we compromise and
we solve the problem.
And I looked at climate and I thought
my gosh, we're not solving the problem,
that we have this huge problem that
could be existential for a society.
And for some reason,
the normal American loud conflictual
compromise isn't happening here.
And I felt like I really
believe in our system, so
I want to get into our
system more to try and
figure out how I can be part of its
normal solution for big problems for us.
And so, I have changed,
actually, my understanding
as a result of getting into that question,
and diving into that problem specifically.
It's changed my understanding
of how America really works.
But the reason I did that problem
was I though it was existential, and
I didn't understand why the normal
American, democratic, ugly, messy,
loud way wasn't working in that case.
>> This gives us a really
good transition over to your
extensive philanthropic work.
You signed onto the giving pledge in 2010.
And you've been especially active
in environmental causes, especially
since that moment that you described
where you saw the light, so to speak.
How did you go about finding
the right causes to back?
>> [LAUGH] By,
I mean, it's such a classic thing.
I think that you learn a lot by doing,
and I think that what we've found
over time is, hopefully,
we're a lot better at what we're doing,
as a result of all the things that
we did that weren't so smart.
And, to a large extent,
I would say, my understanding of
the idea of philanthropy is
really different from what I
would say is a traditional
understanding of philanthropy.
Because actually,
what we've tried to do is to set up
operating enterprises in the real world
that are hands on to actually affect
the kinds of things we're hoping for.
It sounds complicated.
But for instance, we have a community bank
where the equity is through a foundation.
So we can never get the money back.
So in a way, we've given
the money away forever and ever.
But it's a bank that's FDIC insured.
It makes loans for economic justice,
environmental sustainability,
women in minority own businesses.
So it's got a very specific
social thrust done through our
capitalist economic system, but
with a complete value driven agenda.
So it's kind of, we're not giving money
away to people, we're lending money.
We need them to pay us back with interest,
so
we can make more loans to other people,
so they can succeed.
And so that's not, I mean, I've never
heard of someone else doing that,
or thinking of that as philanthropy.
In fact, when we suggest to other
people that it's a good idea,
they look very askance, but
we really believe in operating
enterprises where people are involved,
really in the real world trying
to have impact in a big way, and
also to show that things are possible.
>> Is that a strategy that underlies
your focus on both the Center and
the Tomcat Center here at Stanford?
I mean, you clearly believe that
Stanford has a role to play in
your strategy in fighting climate change.
>> So, one of the things that's true,
if you look at climate, and
you kind of divide it into what
is happening in the real world in terms
of the natural world changes, and
what's happening in terms of research,
and technology, and
capability of dealing with the problems or
solving the problems.
And then our willingness to actually solve
the problems and use the technology and
the techniques that we have I felt as if,
and I still feel like,
I mean, I love Stanford, Stanford
has led revolutions in technology.
I wanted Stanford to use its
broad range of capabilities,
to be a leader in this on every scale.
So from an investment side,
a legal side, a technology side,
I felt like Stanford has done this in IT,
why shouldn't we be doing this in energy?
There are very few places that have
the breadth of research, the sort
of capability of across the board making
this difference, and making it happen.
And so, part of the solution to
this is our ability to solve
it from a technical basis, and then to
understand how that fits into society.
And so, since I love Stanford, and
since I knew the capabilities,
I felt like I would really like
it if Stanford leads on this.
And if you actually look at what
Stanford did on renewing its
own electricity plant for
the campus, that was, I think,
designated the best engineering project
in the United States of America in 2015.
The Stanford electricity system,
so that we have the capability
of doing this in a way that is
significant and replicable, and
that's what I wanted to see.
>> Apparently,
we're also pretty good at football.
[LAUGH]
>> Wow, where I goeth before a fall.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We'll pass on the message to
David Shaw.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But before we go to national politics,
I'd like to focus a bit on your
activism here in our own backyard.
In California,
voter ballot initiatives allow the public
to vote directly on proposed laws.
You have focused on these ballot
initiatives as a way to influence a wide
range of policies, including climate and
energy legislation.
How did you arrive at
this particular approach?
>> So for the people who aren't California
citizens, we do have
this extremely fat and
complicated ballot where you're basically
allowed to do direct democracy.
So if you can get enough
signatures raised,
you can put a proposition on the ballot
that everybody gets to vote on.
And if 50.1% of the people vote for
it, you have a new law.
And this has led to some
truly heinous outcomes, and
it's also led to some
really good outcomes.
And so, the first thing that we did,
was I co-chaired with George Schultz.
Fighting a ballot initiative
which was designed to get
rid of our progressive energy legislation.
Our cap and trade system, and a bunch
of other things that have to do with
basically having the most progressive
energy laws in the world.
That was in 2010,
two oil companies wanted to basically
change those laws and get rid of them.
And so we were the No on 23 campaign.
So why did we, we did that because
traditionally, when you get to
the ballot and it's a question of
business versus environmentalist,
jobs versus the environment,
jobs and business always win.
And that was the way people thought
this was going to happen and
there had been a previous
ballot initiative in 2006.
So four years before, where an individual
from L.A spent 70 million bucks and
lost his initiative.
So there was no one rushing to be the
environmental side of this proposition,
so it's like most of the jobs I've had.
There was no one else
stupid enough to take it.
But the difference was,
it actually was a formative experience for
me because it really was about
climate in some ways but
we had a rule,
no one can talk about climate.
The way that we're going to talk to people
is about local human issues of jobs and
clean air.
And in fact, by far,
the best TV commercial we had was a
commercial of a woman who was the head in
California of the American Lung
Association talking about clean air and
the American Lung Association so
obviously she cared about it.
She was very credible, a lovely person,
came across incredibly well and
we got 70% of the vote for
people who said basically,
we don't want to get rid of our
clean air/climate legislation.
We also found, and I think it was
incredibly significant for me,
that we wanted a different message
which was more jobs, cleaner air.
But we also wanted a completely
different corelation.
So we spent, we knew that all the people
who are traditional environmentalists,
of course,
would be on our side in terms of groups.
The NRDC, EDF,
League of Conservation Voters,
Sierra Club, of course,
those people would be for us.
But actually when you look
at the people of California,
the number one group who supports
everything environmental, everything about
progressive energy, everything
against climate change, are Latinos.
Number two group, African Americans,
number three group Asian Americans.
So when we were looking at
the people of California for
votes, we knew from the beginning we were
going to get progressive business and
we basically split the chambers
of commerce around the state.
We had at least half
the chambers on our side.
We had organized labor but
went to every community group and
we wanted to make sure
that people understood it.
Because actually, the people who
are not necessarily considered members
of the CR club and Mike Brunes once
tried to kill me for saying this.
But people who haven't necessarily been
the, what you think of as the fabled
environmentalists actually
are the environmentalists.
And that's how we got 70% of the vote
because we looked at a completely
different slice of Californians, and
we said our coalition is much broader and
our message is much different.
And that is something that
I learned in that year and
it was true then and it's true now.
>> So
these campaigns you've organized on
behalf of these clauses are not cheap.
[LAUGH] California's all ready one of
the most expensive media markets in
the country and
as these things go national,
I mean the costs grow
almost exponentially.
What would you say to those who argue
that spending massive amounts of money on
these types of campaigns actually
undermines our democratic process?
>> There's no question that the money in
politics is completely out of control and
I would be strongly in favor
of changing the rules.
I completely agree with that, I do think
the money in politics is a cancer and
it's distorting and has led to some
terrible outcomes and continues to.
You really can't look at
this tax bill that's going
through the Congress right now and not
see that that's exactly what's happening.
That we have a fight between
monied interests and the people of
the United States, and the people of
the United States are losing badly.
No question about it.
That happens to be the system we have.
So I could say, you know what,
I wish the system were different and
until the system is different,
I'm going to sit on the sidelines.
Or I could say, I really think
it's important that we keep our
clean energy legislation, I really think
it's important to close this tax loophole,
I really think it's important to
stop young people from smoking and
just suck it up and spend the money.
Or I could be pure and
say I'm going to keep the money and
I'm going to wait until the system is
perfect which will be, by the way, never.
So I do think we should change it.
I'm completely against
Citizens United decision.
I think it's an absolutely
terrible decision for democracy.
I think it is distorting
the way our society is run.
And I'm completely committed to
a change to what I would think of.
If you look at what we do,
I believe the solution to our
problems is broader democracy and
broader participation and more power
to the people of the United States.
So if you look at what our organization
does, we're a grassroots organization.
Last year, with our partners, we knocked
on 12 and a half million doors, we were
on 370 college campuses, we registered
807,000 people in the State of California.
About 350,000 outside.
Every one of those was an attempt to
get people who are under represented
to be registered, engaged,
and to participate.
Because unless you are doing that,
your voice isn't heard and
you are not going to get a fair shake.
So, everything we are doing
is about broader democracy,
more participation by people
who are underrepresented so
that they will get a fair
shake in our democracy.
And the money side of this,
on the other side, is huge and
absolutely contrary to every
single thing we're doing.
And in fact,
they're fighting their head off to try and
prevent Americans from being able
to exercise their franchise and
to participate fully.
>> So I'm hearing you say something very
interesting which is that,
even if Gandhi once said, an eye for
an eye will make the world blind, you're
essentially telling us well, in this case,
two wrongs do make a right.
That if you want to fight,
you have to fight the fight with your own,
with whatever you've got on your arsenal.
>> No, no, no, no.
I will not accept that question.
I am not jabbing anyone's eye out.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That is absolutely unfair.
I believe what they are doing
is anti-democratic And
I believe the only thing I'm doing is
to try and make the democracy broader,
more complete, and more just.
I don't think this is an eye for an eye.
I don't think I'm doing anything
that is not absolutely positive and
in favor of the American system and
the American people.
I'm not doing anything to hurt them.
All I'm trying to do is have
a counterbalance supporting the people of
the United States.
This isn't an eye for an eye.
This is completely different.
This is an attempt to protect a system
that was set up over 200 years ago,
where the idea is everybody is equal,
not every dollar is equal,
but every person is equal.
>> So, and I happen, by the way,
to support a lot of the causes you back.
So, understand this comes
from a really good place.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Wait, George, trust me.
If I disagree with you, I intend to.
>> I'm thinking it would be edifying for
people to understand something.
Which is you've built yourself,
occasionally,
as the left's answer to the Koch Brothers.
>> Never, not one time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you for saying it.
Not once, and never will.
>> Well, I've read it.
>> Someone else has.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I promise, it's never happened.
Other people ask me if I'm the left
answer to the Koch Brothers and
I always say no.
>> All right well,
well challenge accepted I guess.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I've been there every time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, I agree that it's not a fair
characterization to
compare people like that.
But I think one thing that I was curious
to understand is what do you think
the American left, or rather,
just progressive causes in general, and
those who back them,
could learn from the Koch Brothers?
>> Well, I'll say this,
I mean I don't know if you guys,
have you guys read Dark Money?
There's a book about
the Koch Brothers essentially,
kind of going back through their family
history about what they've done from
an economic basis and
what they've done on a political basis.
And they have been really consistent.
They have been pushing on this stuff
really for over a century as a family.
And so, I admire that fact that
they have continued to push on
the things that they care about
over a very long period of time.
And when you've said that, you've said
every single that I appreciate about
them.
>> [LAUGH] We're talking about what can we
learn from them.
And we don't have to appreciate them.
>> Be
consistent.
>> Be consistent.
>> Keep trying.
I think there is no question
that our organization,
I quit my job five years ago and
our organization has been up for
approximately five years.
We're much better today than
we were five years ago.
What we can do in terms
of going door to door,
what we can do on college campuses.
Our capability of making change
is much better because of
the five years that we've
spent improving ourselves.
I mean when we, I thought at Fairlawn,
and I think today,
when I look back at 2017 I'll
say what did we do in 2017?
Did it work?
Didn't it work?
I will also ask is our organization
stronger at the end of the year than
it is at the beginning of the year?
Because there are lots of things you
can do that makes a year be good at
the expense of a long term growth
of your organization capability.
And I always feel like you
want to have good results and
you want to grow your capability.
And so when I think about
what we're trying to do and
what I think progressives should be trying
to do is be aware of that second part.
It's a long-term proposition
to get this country
back on a trajectory of growth and
justice.
And so any one year, any one election
is not going to do it, we've always
gotta be building capability overtime.
>> So
speaking about building capability,
I think it's probably time just to change
topics slightly to one that's
been in the news recently.
I believe I've seen a commercial or two
regarding your love of President Trump.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If Trump invited you to work on climate
change policy at the White House,
would you accept?
>> No, there's absolutely no chance that
the president has any interest in
seriously working on climate policy.
Every single thing he's done,
in the election and
subsequent to the election has been to
work against us having progressive,
objectively derived energy policies.
So there is no chance that he would make
a good faith effort to have me come and
try and come up with a program so
that as a country we could move
forward in a positive way.
And I think that the fact that
I'm saying that, I deeply regret,
I started by saying my belief in
the American system is as long as
you seed to the other person
that they're patriotic,
that they're first goal is
to help the American people.
And that they're driven by a belief
in data objectivity and analysis.
That's the American system.
And if people disagree with you fine,
of course they do.
I mean anyone who's arrogant enough to
think they're always right is really
ridiculous.
So the American system is we may disagree
but as long as you seed good intentions,
then we can work together, and compromise
in the middle, and probably come out with
something better than either party
had at the start of the conversation.
That's my basic belief.
I don't believe for
a second that those are the circumstances
under which that proposal would be made,
and therefore, I wouldn't do it.
>> So
in talking about growing the capability
of your organization, how would you say
this particular campaign to impeach
President Trump grows the capability of
your organization over the long term?
>> So
what we're actually doing,
which I encourage you to sign onto please,
www.needtoimpeach.com, is
trying to give the American
people directly a voice
in this conversation.
And I think it's fair to say,
that the Republicans in Washington D.C.
don't like it and the Democrats in
Washington, D.C. also don't like it.
But the fact of the matter is
we have the technology for
the American people to act
independently and to speak up.
And the voice of the American people in
a democracy is supposed to be dispositive.
And so what we're trying to do is give
Americans an easy way together to
raise their voice because we believe
that we're actually in danger.
That every single day the health and
safety of American citizens is in danger
and that we can't sit by and
pretend that its not happening.
And so when I think about this campaign,
I think about it the same way you ask
me the questions about the proposition.
The propositions are there for
when the government in
Sacramento fails to be able for
the people of California to be
able to enact laws together.
And what we're doing with this
impeachment petition is to try and
give the American people
a chance to do just that.
Even though we can't make laws,
we can, in effect, raise our voice and
change the conversation and say,
there is something desperately
wrong here in the United States.
This is not a partisan appeal.
This is not to Democrats, or
Independents, or Republicans.
This is to everybody who's worried
about the United States of America, and
that is what we are trying to do.
I had a look for the privacy policy
on the impeachment campaign, and
one of the things it says is that
the information that you provide can be
used for, essentially, future outreach.
Is that another objective
of this campaign?
Is that, yes, maybe this campaign raises
awareness to some issues, but does it also
provide a platform for a really devoted
set of followers to be reached out to
over the course of your next objectives?
>> Well I
would love it if we can get a way for
the American people
to have their voice be heard
over a long period of time and
also to provide a place to
basically put out content.
So as far as I'm concerned,
look, we have seen information
technology change the way people
relate in so many different ways.
And the capability of Americans,
we've seen this all over the world.
I mean, we have seen politics
turned upside-down by the ability
of citizens around the world
to communicate real time.
And we've seen it here too,
in the election process.
The question is, is there a way for
Americans to come together in a way so
that we can actually have our voice be
heard when there's something desperately
wrong?
That's what we're trying to do.
>> Thank you so much.
One more question before we turn it
over to the audience for Q and A.
I wanted just to focus back on the GSP
student body for a second and ask you.
If you could be a GSP student again,
and we'd be very fortunate to
have you in our student body, and
wanted to help the environment,
where would you go right now, and why?
>> As
a job?
>> Yes, for
a career.
>> Well,
I'll say this, I don't think there's
one answer to that question.
I have four kids who are 23,
25, 27, and 29.
I think that their generation, so for
everybody who's sitting here
who's in that age range,
I think that your generation actually
is much more thoughtful about the way
that you're thinking about your careers
and your lives than the class of
1983 at the business school where
basically we would like a job.
I think people now are much more proactive
in thinking about what getting that
job will mean and what the implications
are down the line, I really do.
But I think when I look at my four kids,
my oldest son is working
on basically software to
put renewables on the grid.
My second son is an architecture student
who is trying to figure out how to use
the mimicry of nature to make better
spaces for people to live in.
My daughter is working at an impact
investor trying to get good returns, but
also take into account what will mean for
the world if you make the investments.
My youngest son is claims to be
about to take the MCATs, and
he's working on health policy for
a Congressperson from Southern California.
So my answer is,
I don't think there's one answer,
I think that as always you should do the
things that you love and are thrilled by.
But I think that when you do them,
you should do them with a perspective that
you're going to have a lot of impact,
more than you think.
And that the flip side of getting to go
to this incredibly elite institution.
I know people hate hearing that,
everyone would like to think, shucks,
it's nothing special.
It's very special,
people here get an opportunity to have
impact that's absolutely disproportionate.
And I think you should just be aware,
that when you do,
you should take responsibility for
what you're causing.
And that is,
I don't care what your job is,
as long as you're doing that,
as long as you're thinking it through,
and that your values are reasonable,
then you will do good things.
And I think that is the responsibility
of getting all this special stuff,
which I'm extremely grateful
to have gotten myself.
It is a massive opportunity, and with
the massive opportunity, should come some
sense of responsibility that you don't
just get to do this for yourself.
That if you're going to get
this special chance in society,
that you should be thinking about what
that means for your relationship to
all the other people in this society
who didn't get that special chance.
And I think you don't do that, I think
that would be a profound mistake for
someone.
>> We'll now open it up to questions
from the audience.
We've got some microphones.
>> Hi,
Dr. Van Aken, I'm an MBA One here.
Question on why impeachment?
Why not focus on the policy disagreements,
raise those issues with
the American people?
It strikes me from a rhetoric perspective
that saying the man's an existential
threat, he should be removed from office
is to now action impact us a bit confusing
and potentially dangerous, so thank you.
>> So, why impeachment?
Well, I do think the man's
an existential threat, for starters.
I do think that he's met the standard for
impeachment.
And we're actually going to go through
that, I think, in public next week.
But, I also think,
That there is a question in our society,
really, about what we're doing and
whether we're in crisis.
So I look at the impeachment question as,
are we in crisis?
And I talked to a friend of mine,
and I thought he said something,
who runs a very large public company.
And he said Tom, I have a 3% mortgage,
we have 4% unemployment,
and the sock market is at a record,
how are we in crisis?
And I said well the markets fluctuate,
economies change around.
But if you look what was
going on politically,
if you look at what's going on
internationally, if you look at what's
going on in terms of long term decisions,
for the United States of America's,
we are in a profound crisis that
people are not dealing with.
And that is the point of impeachment.
People are saying to me,
actually I'm never going to use this
when they don't like a tax bill.
This has nothing to do with a tax bill.
We are in a profound crisis and the
question is when are Americans going to be
able, are we going to as a group realize
this and understand what's at stake?
So I actually think that going
after the individual bills,
all of which I disagree with, every single
one of them, is the wrong way to do it.
That that is something where
you're really fighting in DC.
I don't want to be fighting in DC.
I don't think it's going to be effective.
I think it's a waste of time and money.
What I want to be doing is I want to
be talking to people in Des Moines,
and Schenectady, and
Cleveland, and Dallas, and
all across the country,
because those are the people who I trust.
I keep saying the solution for
us is going to be a broader democracy,
not to go back to Washington DC to
beg people to be more thoughtful.
>> To build on that question a little bit,
you've fielded many
questions about whether or
not this impeachment campaign is setting
up a run for governor of California, and
I'm not going to repeat that question.
That talking about whom
you're fighting on behalf of.
I guess I was curious, what would you want
potential voters to know about you based
on this impeachment campaign?
>> About me?
>> Yes, because you're the one fighting
for them.
>> [LAUGH] Well,
I don't think it's about me.
Let's start by saying this
campaign is supposed to be about
everybody putting their voice together.
The only thing I'd really like
people to understand is I think that
most of the people who interview me
ask me what my hidden agenda is.
And there's an assumption in there that no
one would do something because they just
thought it was the right thing to do,
that there has to be something.
I remember when I started on climate,
people would say to me, but
you're doing this to make money on
your clean energy investments, right?
And I'd be like, how does spending
tens of millions of dollars that has
no response make people richer?
It's-
>> [LAUGH]
>> But we actually made sure we made no
clean energy investments except
through our foundation, so
that we could just take
that off the table.
So when I think about this impeachment,
my whole point on this is
we're trying to do what's right,
because we think it's important.
That's what I want people to think,
that's all we want.
We want Americans to think
that there is a possibility to
do what's right, and
that is what we are pushing for
as hard as possible.
>> Hi, my name's Tyler Willerbram, MBA 1.
And I'm curious to know, so, investing
all this money in technologies for
sustainable energy, and trying to
influence policies to promote them.
But people largely ignore the fact that if
you just got rid of fossil fuels today,
you'd be having thousands of people
unemployed all of a sudden across the US.
And largely this happened
in the coal industry, and
is definitely a factor that led to
the results of this past election.
So to claim that we need to get to get to
sustainable energy as quickly as possible,
but ignore this really
large fact of doing so
could actually result in electing even
more in the same potential president.
What's sort of your response to,
what are you doing to actually look at
the American workers and people that
are going to be voting in these elections
to ensure that if we do get to
a sustainable energy across the grid,
how do we actually make sure that
we're not leaving other people behind?
>> So, that is a great question.
And before I give my answer,
let me apologize for my answer,
because I completely disagree
with almost everything you said.
We actually did a study on this.
So we did a study what happens to
employment if we move to clean energy.
We can't move to clean energy tomorrow.
It's always going to
be a question of pace.
But we did a study with Hank Paulson,
the Republican Secretary of
the Treasury under George W Bush, and
Mike Bloomberg, who's been a Democrat, a
Republican, and is sort of an independent,
I guess, to make sure that it
wasn't a partisan's fight.
And it basically showed, that in fact, if
we moved to clean energy, it creates more
jobs, that we will have higher paying
jobs, the United States will grow faster.
And this isn't taking into account
the cost of having the climate change,
and the kinds of disasters that
are going to cost the United States $300
billion this year.
But there are a couple true points in
what you're saying that are absolutely
important politically, and I agree with.
One of them has to do with
what are you going to do with.
It's true there will be more jobs, and
it's true the jobs will be better paying,
but not for the same people.
So the question is,
what are you going to do?
My roommate, my ex-roommate lives in
the poorest county in West Virginia.
His brother-in-law is
an unemployed coal miner, and
his cousin is an unemployed coal miner.
So I went down to see him,
he's a retired career army officer
with some health problems.
And I went down, and he was telling me,
if you're a coal miner today,
you make 82 bucks an hour.
Which, in the poorest county in West
Virginia, is an unbelievable amount of
money, and the next stop is
probably 25 bucks an hour.
So coal mining is not
the world's greatest job.
It's a really well paid
job with good benefits.
And that's really what
we're talking about.
We're talking about what are we going
to do for the people in our society who
think, look, there are 50,000 coal
miners in the United States of America.
It's a very, very, very,
very small number of people,
but there's a broader question here,
and that's what Trump was referring to.
There are a group of people in the United
States of America who do not live in
Palo Alto, California.
They do not live in New York City.
They do not live in the parts of
the country that are seeing real growth.
They are not connected to
the information technology revolution.
They are not connected to the positive
aspects of globalization.
And they can see the climate changing,
but for
them, that is not the immediate
problem they're dealing with.
That's just something that
may put them out of work.
So they feel completely
scared by the fact,
all of the fact that
the world is changing.
That people in Palo Alto go like, whoa,
just killed it on my latest investment.
They're going, whoa, the world is
changing, and they just closed the plant.
And there's only one plant, or
they just closed the coal mine, and
now what do we do?
But now we're going to get less than half
the dollars per hour that we thought we
were going to get or that we were getting.
So the question to me is not
the macro question you asked,
but the micro question.
What do we say to the people
in rural America or
poor urban America who are not
connected to the growth for
whom the rapid pace of change in
our society is scary as anything?
And that is what Trump was dealing with,
that fear, that uncertainty, and
that sense that no one was listening.
And I think his answer
was a dishonest one.
And I think it was absolutely, we're
not going back to a lot of coal miners.
Even if we dug a ton more coal,
it's all mechanized.
No one is going into a coal face with
a pick and shovel anymore, period.
But it was a perfect symbol for
going back to a time when being
a hard working American who was
willing to go to work every day and
kill yourself meant you got a middle
class job, including in rural America.
So the question is when we talk to those
people who are hard working and scared,
how are we actually,
not how are we going to fake it,
how are we actually going to include them?
And to me, the question is two-fold.
One is, we need to invest in
the people of the United States.
That means education, training.
We need to connect them to this world
that you guys are in right here in this
auditorium.
If you don't have
broadband in the community,
you cannot compete in the first world.
When I was in West Virginia,
the roads were bad, literally.
So the question is,
if you're in that community,
how can you possibly compete in this
world or even be part of this world?
And this includes rural California.
If you're not connected real-time,
it can't happen.
Secondly, if we're not investing in
those people, we lose, they lose,
the country loses.
The idea that we're going to
cut education, training,
healthcare, food for
poor kids from the budget is insane.
It's morally wrong, but it's also crazy.
This country will do well
if Americans do well.
We should be taking our money and
investing in those people.
So that they think I'm going
to be connected to the world,
I'm going to be trained for the world.
I'm going to participate in this world,
in the 21st century, so that every change
doesn't actually push me further away
from what's going on in the real world.
Because if we were in rural Wisconsin,
and there was one plant in our town,
and that plant closed, we wouldn't
know what to do either, except leave.
That's what's going on in this world.
We need to invest and frankly, clean
energy, it means rebuilding this country,
and it actually means this country
with millions of net new jobs.
We have to do it.
It's a way for us in the short-term to get
every community rural, poor urban people.
People in rural America,
we have to do it every where.
It's good jobs every where.
The question is,
what do the jobs pay and who gets them?
The last thing I'll say is this, I was
in Cleveland talking to some inner city
ministers about clean energy jobs,
and they were excited,
I promise you, at the idea that we
could bring thousands of jobs to urban,
poor Cleveland with high unemployment for
their people, in their communities.
It's true in rural Wisconsin too.
So when I hear it I know he's talking,
the president was dealing with
a real emotional problem that is
absolutely felt in this country but
he wasn't giving a fair answer.
And the answer I'm giving about invest
in Americans, rebuild the country and
connect us all together, is actually the
way that somebody living in a rural part
of this country can connect
with you guys in this room.
Or you can choose to live in
a rural part of California and
still connect with the fastest growing,
most vibrant companies in the world.
>> We are almost out of time,
so I'm just going to take the final
question, so we can wrap up, so
officially according to the clock.
But the holidays are right around the
corner, and I've read that you are known
for requiring guests at your annual
Christmas lunch to bring a poem to read.
What's the best poem you've heard?
Well, I would say there are some
great American poets right now.
The two that I would recommend to you if
you're not reading your poetry every night
before bed, Billy Collins is hilarious and
really profound and
Mary Oliver is fantastic and super fun.
And wow, if you read just those two poets,
they are, I promise you,
you will laugh really hard and
you will walk away happier, and
with a sense of some, the world being
a place where we can all make it better.
We can have a positive impact.
And that's what we're all trying,
the one thing I would say to you guys is,
look, having a meaningful life
is what you should be going for.
That is what will make you happy.
If you sit there and
think I'm having a positive impact.
I'm having a meaningful life.
That is what you will
want when you're my age.
And so when people say you're really
trying to do this to make more money,
I'm like no, selfishly I'm trying
to have a positive impact.
I'm not trying to say it's not selfish.
But that's what, I promise you guys,
if you're doing that,
you will find great joy in that, and
that's what I've observed in myself and
all the people who I meet.
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in thanking Tom.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]